and and then there's six nine
did you watch the documentary about six
nine on hulu yeah i've had the pleasure
of watching three six nine documentaries
because they interviewed me for all
three oh wow so i kind of wanted to see
all three and i'll be honest with you
though
documentary making has come so far
because they managed to each documentary
managed to tell his story in such a
different way with using different
characters telling the story valid
versions of it yeah they're all pretty
valid yeah i was actually it made me
learn a lot about documentary making
because i saw all the different routes
that they were able to go with that
subject matter you know you know like my
take i only watched the one i believe it
was on hulu and it was like daniel
hernandez or whatever and um i remember
my takeaway being like you know
the only thing that really uh i think
kind of made him look bad was just at
the very end like with his baby mama
saying like uh about like kind of not
being there for the kid
oh man she said crazy [ __ ] about him
like she said that he beat her and raped
her and all this wild [ __ ]
which
surprisingly kind of went under the
radar like didn't really get that much
attention because i feel like people had
already decided that they thought he was
a bad guy and then she came out with
like
a really [ __ ] up story about all how
[ __ ] up he was to her and i felt like
people didn't really pay that much
attention to it which is i mean she's
like a really great person from my
perspective too and like yeah i mean he
really is kind of like the super villain
of rap because he's just kind of burnt
everybody along the way
it's crazy dude
i mean it's it's crazy and like we were
talked on your podcast about
people who get caught up in
maintaining like the appearance of super
success and just being flashy with cars
and money and and everything but then
they fall off and they still need to try
to
maintain this appearance but it's beyond
their means to do so
you've got to believe that
that's kind of the boat he's in
like paying taxes you know a lot of
those people don't pay taxes for three
four years like on tmz this was this has
got to be the most uncomfortable look
like on tmz he's he's uh trying to
reconcile
like having like this like
blocks of cash and saying this is
millions of dollars this is how i live
this is my lifestyle i'm rich i'm rich i
got i got houses on my arms like yeah
what's the house
250. uh in florida [ __ ]
that'll give you a lot of the way there
right yeah
80 in florida but but but meanwhile
while he's saying this i'm rich this is
my lifestyle this is real
like he's saying to the judge in a
lawsuit situation that he's broke and
doesn't have any money and then he's
talking to tmz with harvey levin and
saying look man like i'm an entertainer
so it's like so you're you're well
didn't 50 cent do that too i was in that
same exact situation but the thing about
six nine is that he
will come out and make songs talking
[ __ ] about other rappers who are actual
like real deal gang members who like are
on some crazy [ __ ] that we could not
even imagine how much murder and
bloodshed they've seen both their
enemies getting killed and their family
getting killed and then meanwhile 69
will be calling them out trying to
provoke them to do something violent and
then also meanwhile i mean he is a
federal witness he is required by law to
tell the feds everything that they want
to know
and he still he's so addicted to the
idea of being perceived as a gangster
that he's out here like really trying to
pretend that while also having to stay
in consistent communication with the fbi
is that something that's an ongoing
thing yeah yeah i think he has to check
in like and that's why i think people
are so people don't want to be for them
he's like look how [ __ ] hip-hop is
nobody has killed me
and then everybody who actually kills
people is like i'm not killing you you
got the [ __ ] the feds in your back
pocket like any kind of beef that we
start with you is gonna be reiterated to
them right yeah he's probably being
watched 24 7. everything's tapped i mean
there's got to be like no precedent for
like someone who's turned like uh
states witness or whatever federal
informant and like normally you go into
like a witness protection program but
this [ __ ] guy they tried to get him
to do that and he didn't even want to
have personal security and that's why
like there's a video of him going into a
gas station and he's just buying
something you could tell he's like alone
or like maybe there's a girl in the car
and he's got a bag that he's wearing
right here and he's got his hand in it
like you could tell he's holding his gun
while he's going in the 7-eleven to buy
a [ __ ] soda
and it's like he's got some guy like
filming him talking [ __ ] in the gas
station and it's like that's the reality
of his life is that he's got to be ready
to [ __ ] he's either gonna roll
security all the time or he's gotta be
ready to shoot somebody at any time
right and then
like you can't afford security anymore
because like no one will [ __ ] with you
and you're not making money yeah that's
like one of the great mysteries because
i mean i i know he could go play shows
overseas and stuff and make [ __ ] loads
of money but then i also like yeah i'm
pretty sure his financial situation is
like ridiculously expensive and he has
all these legal situations i don't know
dude it's it's it's not um
the [ __ ] uh
i said
yeah it's just so fascinating um what
what was he just put out a
song recently and it was like pretty
good right
it didn't do that well nobody was like
riding on the car through new york like
on top of it yeah i mean it really felt
like it was kind of attached to like an
energy drink somehow yeah he started an
energy drink and an nft collection
called jeanne
okay the nft collection did pretty good
i think right i would really doubt that
i'm gonna be honest with you like
these are not like having a good
reputation it's not a great market right
now but i think especially if you're a
rapper pushing an nft that the fans are
even more turned off because there was a
while there where everybody was trying
to get me to do a [ __ ] nft collection
and trying to pay me like let me give
you 40 grand to say that you're [ __ ]
with my nft and i'm just like it took me
a while to understand and then by the
time i really fully understood i was
like i'm glad that i said no to almost
all of this i might have posted a couple
of them but i sold one really like uh
not like backing anybody else's nftc i
just created one and put it on a thing
right sold it for what at the time uh i
saw one east which at the time was like
three thousand bucks
and
so you set up like a crypto wallet kind
of a thing right and and uh
did the
password is like a series of words and
everything you know i write it down on a
[ __ ] box you lost it yeah
my editor threw it away
i indeed my my i'm like dude you [ __ ]
me you threw away my east and he goes
dude i'll wait until it crashes i'll pay
back
i think that clip was awesome but not as
awesome as my new book a hard kick in
the nuts what i've learned from a
lifetime of terrible decisions which is
out september 27th and if you pre-order
it right now you can get the autographed
copy so get on it man pre-order my book
it's not going to waste your time
because i'm proven dude new york times
bestseller my first books five star
rated on amazon and i have no doubt this
one will be two so get the autographed
copy right now
by pre-ordering it at stevo.com
yeah dude